bonjour et bienvenue dans ce tome
science consacrée aujourd'hui aux
fossiles et commençons tout d'abord par
un chiffre 99.999 naf naf naf naf naf et
cetera % des espèces et qui vivent ou
ont vécu ont aujourd'hui disparu
cela signifie que d'un point de vue
strictement mathématique
nous sommes tous déjà
beaucoup de choses sont qualifiés à tort
de fossiles comme le rayonnement que
c'est résiduelle du big bang qu'on peut
voir sur une télé ou bien encore des
possibles vivent en effet car on ne le
répétera jamais assez mais pour être un
fossile
il faut être aux morts et non pas de
donc pour être un fois ci il faut être
mort en fait un fossile vivant si ça
devait exister
ce serait ça
qualifié un animal des fossiles vivants
c'est se figurer qu'il n'a pas évolué ce
qui dénote plus une méconnaissance des
fossiles de l'animal en question que
d'une réalité scientifique
c'est ainsi que les pauvres recaser
crocodiles sont injustement qualifiées
de fossiles vivants alors que leurs
représentants actuels ne sont pas du
tout représentative de ce que furent les
espèces d'autrefois
et d'ailleurs même si parfois certaines
espèces comme le coelacanthe où il
élimine n'ont pas l'air d'avoir évolué
il faut bien garder à l'esprit que seuls
5 % de nos gènes sont responsables de
notre apparence physique et par
conséquent de ce à quoi ressembleront
les fossiles etc qui laisse aux 95 % ne
gène en laissant la possibilité
d'évoluer librement
si la notion de fossiles vivants autant
la cote c'est surtout parce qu'elle fait
marcher le commerce est qu'elle permet
de faire les gros titres des journaux
donc finalement un fossile se sont et
restent préservés dans la roche d'un
organisme ou d'un morceau d'organismes
qui fut autrefois vivant mais ça peut
aussi être toute trace pétrifié d'une
activité animal comme une empreinte de
pas par exemple un terrier dekeister
géant ou bien encore un coprolithe c'est
à dire une jolie blouse cette race qui
contrairement à un squelette ont été
faites du vivant de l'animal nous en
apprennent d'ailleurs énormément sur
leur mode de vie
et puis c'était émouvant de se dire
qu'il ya une centaine de millions
d'années de cela à dinosaures dépassé
par là à part à faire joli encore ps
discutent et à faire le plein de
combustibles fossiles
les fossiles certes aussi et surtout aux
scientifiques pour leurs travaux dès le
xviiie siècle le génial cuvier avait par
exemple remarquer que chaque strate
géologique contenait à l'assemblage de
possibles différents qui permettait
ainsi de les dater et ils inventer et à
stratigraphie le tout aussi génial
darwin quand il publia sa théorie de
l'évolution par la sélection naturelle
en 1859 a quant à lui assez largement
négligé les fossiles affirmant qu'étant
donné les connaissances de son époque
l'absence d'intermédiaire entre les
espèces dans les couches géologiques
constituer le plus grand handicap de sa
théorie mais une darwin sur ce coup-là
eu tort puisque à peine dix ans plus
tard en 1863 et l'écrit archéoptéryx qui
avec sa queue et s'aidant de dinosaures
et ses plumes d'oiseaux constituer la
parfaite démonstration de ce qu'il
existe des formes intermédiaires dans
leur registre fossile
et qu'il documente l'évolution en
offrant un accès direct à une dimension
qu'il manque à toutes les autres
sciences de l'évolution le temps au fait
savez vous qui à décrire cotherix non au
nom pas encore lui mais c'est un [ __ ]
ou quoi
mais passons sans transition au nom
condamne aux fossiles
les scientifiques ont beaucoup donné de
petits surnoms à leur petit possible
comme ce fut le cas pour l'uci en
référence à la chanson des beatles ou
bien paul hamm de flore est surnommé le
hobbit en référence à sa petite taille
prince ou bien encore bghal parce que
c'est un allosaure et parce qu'il est
baba parce qu'il est gros quoi mais pour
donner un prénom un fossile
il faut avant tout définir une nouvelle
espèce les espèces actuelles sont
délimités par le fait que les individus
qui la composent peuvent ou non seul
couple et entre eux et donner une
descendance qui sera elle-même fertile
ça c'est bien beau mais sur les fossiles
c'est pas facile à voir
en fait en paléontologie des individus
suffisamment différent du point de vue
morphologique pourront raisonnablement
être considérés comme appartenant à deux
espèces distinctes
c'est un peu arbitraire effectivement
mais ça donne quand même une bonne idée
de la biodiversité passé dans la plupart
des cas encore qu il arrive que des
espèces considérées comme bien
distinctes se révèle en fait capable de
se croiser ce fut le cas entre notre
espèce et l'homme de néandertal
il y à entre 80 et 30 mille ans
au passage des néandertaliens nous ont
quand même refilé 4% de leurs gènes pour
faire un bon nom d'espèce il y a une
recette prenez d'abord un prénom comme
tyrannosaurus ou homo on appelle ce
prénom le nom de genre ajoutez ensuite
un nom de famille ou non d'espèces comme
par exemple rex ou sapiens le plus
souvent ces mots sont en latin mais ils
peuvent aussi être très très alambiquées
voir à coucher dehors comme gamarra
cantus quito derma gamarus laurie cateau
baïkal en six nommés par dibowski en
1926 c'est non mais c'est quoi cette
belle tu là bas c'est juste une crevette
pour donner un nom à une espèce il faut
le justifier par écrit car ces noms
restent à lytham internet sauf à
certaines conditions bien précises et
c'est parfois bien dommage que ces noms
ne puisse pas être changé
cela permettrait par exemple pauvre
scarabée à 9 talmud et léry nommé ainsi
en l'honneur d'hitler en 1933 de ne plus
être collectionnées abusivement par les
adorateurs du troisième reich
de temps en temps les naturalistes se
lâche et donne des noms farfelus avec
des justifications toutes aussi
farfelues les justifications peuvent
même être parfois plus intéressante que
le nom d'espèce lui-même
prenez par exemple des tortues ninja
mais le relais avec ricciardo wayne et
vous obtiendrez nîmes génisses owen qui
signifie littéralement la tortue ninja
de web ainsi nommé je cite en référence
à ce redoutable super quatuor
symbolisant le succès des êtres à
caracas une espèce de lézard fossiles
fait même nommé obama dont comprenait
les dents d'obama en l'honneur de la
politique pour l'hygiène bucco-dentaire
menée par le président obama
il faut dire aussi que le fossile
consiste en une mâchoire plein dedans
on peut aussi nommer une espèce en
l'honneur d'une illustre personnage
comme à nantes guerra spielberg qui fut
nommé en l'honneur de steven spielberg
le réalisateur de jurassic park ou méo
par api lequel s michael jackson i un
crabe nommé en l'honneur de michael
jackson ou annonce un fred astaire
grillades et ricky est un habile jeu de
mots entre la terminaison qu'on donne
traditionnellement au nom d'espèce
d'oursins astaire et le nom de la
célèbre star hollywoodienne frédéric
astaire certains sont même allés très
loin
en nommant un python possible
typique de nos idoles en l'honneur la
tat thanh raja ça laisse moi deviner les
monty python
les groupes de musique ne sont pas
épargnés comme king diamond un groupe de
métal qui inspire le long d'un verre
possible si une tête d'ail à mon bien le
personnage honoré peut même être fictif
c'est le cas du trio beat qu'on a nommé
du nom du héros de la guerre des étoiles
est un solo beaucoup d'autres sujets
peuvent faire l'objet d'une
justification
ce peut être un plat par exemple comme
celui qui a été mis à l'honneur par
acquis les mises cassoulet ti ou une
particularité physique du fossile peut
aussi servir à le nommer comme par
exemple un formes suggestives du scrotum
humaine et qui s'est avéré être en fait
un genou de mega l'osar on retrouve le
même genre de déviance pour des espèces
actuelles comme le phallus impudique us
à la forme les contes et légendes sont
aussi à l'honneur avec x calibre aux
risques austin il reptile marin rostas
en forme d'épée les références
mythologiques ne sont pas en reste
qu'elle soit égyptienne nordique au
biblique
ce dernier leviathan melvillei le
cachalot tueur préhistorique découverts
au pérou n'est d'ailleurs certainement
pas étranger au personnage de puces dans
l'âge de glace 4
loin d'être des cas isolés les noms
d'espèces originaux sont même très
répandu en particulier quand il s'agit
de nommer des espèces actuelles c'est
ainsi que lady gaga s'est retrouvé avec
une fougère est un moustique portant son
nom
la ressemblance est en effet troublante
et beyoncé a même sa propre espèce de
mouche parce que je cite comme elle son
popotin vaut de l'or est il donc le
mieux la matt groening créateur des
simpson le prince charles
yoda ou encore dark vador ont tous ce
point en commun ils ont une espèce
alors non si le fait de donner des noms
curieux bizarre ou en forme de clin
d'oeil a pour effet de faire sortir la
science de sa tour d'ivoire ce n'est pas
tant par souci de diffusion du savoir
que pour faire part
toi oui car en sciences comme partout
ailleurs le productivisme et roy et les
scientifiques sont soumis à la dure loi
du publier ou périr
vous devez poser si public autonome il
faut pouvoir mettre en avant ses
recherches à tout prix afin d'espérer
récolter des 6000 et on se demande bien
jusqu'à quel point les chercheurs iront
pour faire parler d'eux car même si
paillage universitaire d'un
paléontologue bitam et de reconnaître
n'importe quel animal à l'aide d'un
fragment aussi petit soit-il vouloir
faire une nouvelle espèce à partir de
ceux-ci
ça relève plus du gag que de la science
et c'est encore plus vrai quand on sait
que ce petit bout de leurs beats d'un
dinosaure a été baptisé sort omnium ce
qui signifie un oeil de soro en
l'honneur de l'oeil le plus célèbre de
tous les temps
en conclusion en donnant l'accès à la
dimension du temps
les fossiles sur le point d'ancrage de
toutes les sciences de l'évolution et
pour prédire les tendances futures comme
celle de l'évolution du climat par
exemple il faut impérativement connaître
celles du passé et les fossiles son le
point d'ancrage obligé avant d'effectuer
toute forme de prédiction car sans
mémoire du passé il n'ya pas
d'anticipation possible ce stop sur
s'est terminé merci de l'avoir suivi
pour en savoir plus nous vous
conseillons la lecture du guide critique
de l'évolution
et oui encore et vous pouvez aussi
consulter le site dont l'adresse est
dans la description
merci à tous